Merhaba Merhabalar Hoş
geldiniz Ben
Özge ilk önce çok kısaca kendimi
tanıtayım gururla söyleyebileceğim gibi
2000 tör mezunuyum O zaman okulun adı
değildi in Lisesi ama adı farklı olsa da
kültür O ruh çok benzerdi O yüzden bugün
Sizin karşınızda olmaktan inanılmaz
büyük onur ve mutluluk
duyuyorum burada mı durmam gerekiyor
Pardon büyük onur ve mutluluk duyuyorum
Öyle ki nerede duracağımı karıştırdım
e Biliyorum bu genç arkadaşları
etkilemek çok zor Umarım 15 dakikanızı
iyi değerli geçirmenize yardımcı olurum
2000 Tor mezunuyum dahaa sonra Birkent
Üniversitesi'ne girdim endüstri
mühendisliği Eee Oradan sonra da Eee
p'de işe başladım Eee Finans
departmanında 3 sene finansta çalıştım
daha sonra İpana Oral be Prima gibi
markalarda çalıştım baktım Prada
çalışırken Bu arada evlenmiştim
pazarlamaya geçerken baktım firmada
çalışırken herkes Çocuk yapıyor Ben Niye
yapmayayım dedim ve ilk doğum iznine
ayırdım Oğlum Ali Doğu şurada doğada
gördüğümüz çok göremediğiniz üzer Nur
inmiş daha sonra
Eee marka operasyonlarında birçok
markadan sorumlu olarak çalışmaya
başladım bütün ev bakım kategorilerinin
pazarlama planlarını yapmaya başladım
Daha sonra da yine primaya bakıyordum
aynı dönemde ve ik doğum izen ayrıldım
Bu sefer de kızım aramıza katıldı yine
şu yukarıda gördüğünüz
e ik doğum izninden sonra da ipan ore
tekrar geri döndüm Şu an ağız bakım
kategorisinde marka müdürü olarak
çalışıyorum pcde
hala asl Ben slı hep kullanıyorum yani
her eğitimim bir sunum yapacağım zaman
kendimi tanıtm gerektiğinde bu slı
kullanıyorum ve şunu fark ettim ilk işe
girdiğimde Burada bir sürü hobi vardı
yok felsefe yok işte sporat Bilmem şimdi
gördüğünüz gibi sadece çocuk iş Bir de
okullar mezun Old Bir de şurada
gördüğünüz kiloları
ha anlatıyor diyebilirim
Eee Ben bugün kendini Ada başarıya
ulaşmak için neler yaptığınız da ilgili
konuşacağım sizin için biraz daha yakın
olması adına
Eee başarı diye bahsettiğim şeyin
Eee ÖSS'de şimdi adı da değişmiştir
kesin üniversite sınavında Türkiye 14S
olup Bilkent Üniversitesi endüstri
mühendisliğine bursu olarak girmek ve
onu 7inc likle bitirmek Eee ve
sonrasında pcye kabul almak diye
düşünebilirsiniz bugün size anlatacağım
başarı ama aslında bu bir başarı değil
bu kesinlikle bir başarı değil Bu bir
yarış ve Aslında gerçek başarı bu
yarıştan sıyrıl bilmek ne için sizin
için başarının tanımı Neyse benim için
başarının tanımı mutlu olmaktı O
yüzden Eminim siz sormuşsunuz Ben bu
soruyu ilk kendime sorduğumda 30'lu
yaşardım sizin için başarının tanımını
yapın yani bu İlla çok
ülkemi kurtaracağım İşte şu sorunu
çözeceğim şehrimi kurtaracağım Er
izleyenler varsa Han Starling City
kurtaracağım falan gibi
şeyler olmayabilir Benimki daha Beylik
daha böyle işte hani bir iş bulurum
ailemi kurarım mutlu olurum gibi bir
şeydi o yüzden aslında bu yarıştan
sarılabilmek benim için büyük başarıydı
Peki bunu nasıl
yaptım ST K diye çok beğendiğim çok hani
etkilendiğim eğitimlerini aldığımda
kitaplarını okuduğumda hayatıma çok
uyguladığım bir yazar var ve ST Cin'in
bir kitabı var etkili insanların y
alışkanlığı diye bugün çok kısaca bu
süreç içerisinde bu alışkanlıkları y
alışkanlıktan bahsedeceğim ve bu
alışkanlıkları nasıl hayata geçirdiğimi
örneklerle o dönemden komik seçmeye
çalıştığım örneklerle size çok kısa
Anlatmaya
çalışacağım bir alışkanlı Pr Ne demek
bu ve etki edebileceğin şeylere odaklan
edemeyecekler değil özetle Hani
Görselleştirmek
gerekirse diyor ki bir endişe dairesi
var bir de etki dairesi var endişe
dairesi bizim aklımıza takılan
düşündüğümüz Kafa yorduğum her şey
dünyada açanlar var gibi etki dairesi
ise bizim etki edebileceğimiz alan gize
sokaklarındaki aç insanlar gibi
düşünebilirsiniz mesela tken son senemde
çokk bir ajanda içindeydim Bugün de çok
Sizin içind farklı oldu düşünmüyorum
Engin birçok kişiniz var birçok yere
yetişmen lazım başka Okullardaki
arkadaşlarınız belki sadece üniversite
sınavına hazırlanırken sizin aynı
zamanda çok güçlü akademik programı çok
ağır akademik programı sosyal
aktiviteleri hepsine yetişmen gerekiyor
Ben bununla ilgili endişelerimi şikayet
etmek yerine odaklanıp bu durumu
avantajım çevirmeye çalıştım dedim Evet
Bu bir realite herkes ama biz başka bir
sürü yaptığımız şey var ve Hani oaman
mesel sonları dershaneye gitmek yoktu En
azından okul programını düzenini hiçbir
şeyini değiştirmiyor ama hafta sonları
dershaneye gidebilir miyizi zorladık
oldu Hem üniversiteyi kazanildimi
akademik programı takip ettim ve üstün
sosyal hayatı da aynı şekilde yaşamaya
devam
edebildim burada önemli olan şey etki
dairesinin büyüyebilmesi Siz ne zamanki
endişe dairesinde değiştiremeyeceğiniz
şeylere de odaklanıp onlar için üzülmeyi
bıraktığınızda inanılmaz bir enerji
inanılmaz bir zaman açığa çıkıyor bu
zaman da Gebze'deki aç çocukları ya da
insanları yardımcı olmaya harcadığınız
bir anda görüyorsunuz ki o iş gebzeden
çıkmış işte Kocael gelmiş ve Gittikçe
büyüyor ik alışkanlık sonunu düşünerek
işe başla Bu benim gözlemim hani bizlere
göre Sizlerde çok daha fazla olan bir
şey Ne istediğinizi biliyorsunuz
gerçekten bizim nesil pek bilmiyordu
bayağı net bilmiyordu
bilor
Timi stajında arçek deyim Gebze'de çevri
ovadaki çamaşır makinesi fabrikasında ve
eee bir dersi alamadım işte sonra
düşündüm ya ben bu dersi alamıyorum
worke gittiğimde bana zaten derslerden
not da vermeyecekler sadece hani comp
diye Kredi verecekler krediyi aldım diye
E o zaman dedim Benim ortalamam
düşebilir blye gidersem ben dedim Şu
maziyi bir arayım dedim Çünkü niye
amacım MEye girmek ya ondan sonra staj
sırasında antes ole telefondan
internetten
buğum aradım y onlar enteresan bir
şekilde açtı ondan son insan kaynakları
benöz ben staj ymak istiyorum Siz ded
yurt dışında ex dah em veriyorsunuz
yoksa ortalı daha em veriyorsunuz dedi
Biz ortalam bakıyoruz
döle kım
Amer geli
gitm ne son
dah
is arı sık sık kafama geliyor ve o
yüzden size çok komik gelecek ama bir
tane Excel dosyam var E ne istiyorum
isimli ve ben o Excel dosyasına
önümüzdeki bir sene 3 sene 5 sene ve 10
sene sonra nerede olmak istediğimi
yanına olasılıklarla koyuyorum Çünkü
İlla net olmak istediğim bir şey yok
hani % 40 bir şey istiyorum da % 60 bir
şey istiyorum ve oraya giden yolda
Mesela 10 yıl sonra olmak İstediğim yere
göre 5 tutarlı mı 3 tutarlı mı bir
tutarlı mı bunun kontrolünü Yapı
Gerçekten bu çok büyük fark yaratıyor
Nereye gitmek
istiyorsunuz ve başarının tanımları ne
ve o tanımları oluşturacak aksiyon
plan alışkanlık önemli işl öncelik Bun
ben çözemedim
aık şöyle
söyleyim
biraki
çıkıyoruz
ve Ben genelde 5'ten Başlıyorum o daha
kolay olabiliyor daha hemen beni tatmin
ediyor olabiliyor E buna bir örnek benim
yine üniversite sınavına hazırlık
sürecinden vereceğim çok yoğun bir
dönemdi Ama ben demiştim ki son 15 gündü
galiba Ben her sabah 10'da işte 99'da
kalkacağım Kahvaltımı yapacağım ve 10da
bir tane deneme sınavı çözeceğim geçmiş
yılların sınavlarını çözeceğim Bu benim
için o an baktığınızda çok büyük bir
Eee fedakarlık ya da bir bir zaman
ayırmayı çok ciddi bir commitment o
yüzden Ama bunu çok uyguladım yani ne
olursa olsun o gün Canım istemiyor
olabilir işim olabilir bilmem ne falan
hiç Hayır her sabah kalkıyordum ve bir
deneme sınavı yapıyordum Yani gerçekten
sizin için o dönemde Önemli olan neyse
üniversite sınavından önceki 15 gün
benim için önemli olan o sınavları
yapmak ve kendime orada bir rutin
oluşturmaktı bunu çok büyük bir şeyle
özenle yaptım 4 alış
burada
ıi kime güv yüksek güv Dayı ilşkiler
sayes daha et
işi şu kurs
eği Güven
hü
iin güv Eğer güvenmezseniz paralize
olursunuz hiçbir şey yapamazsınız
insanlara ilişkilere organizasyonlara
kurumlara süreçlere takımlara güvenmek
zorundasınız Eğer bir takımda güven
yoksa o takım sadece Kaos içinde yaşar O
yüzden güven çok önemli Eğer şimdi bu
yaşınızda insanlar size güvenmiyorsa
okul müdürünüz olur anneniz babanız olur
başkası olur onlara söyleyin bunun ne
kadar önemli olduğunu anlatın ki sizin
nesil bizim nesile göre Bunu zaten çok
daha iyi
yapıyor
alışkan
son
ih yapan kişi sen dedi kurumsal Finans
mı istiyorsun yoksa Maliyet Muhasebesi
Pardon Finans analiz mi istiyorsun yoksa
Maliyet Muhasebesi
istiyorsun Benim konuyla ilgili en ufak
bir fikrim yok yani ben o dönemde bırak
Hani finansal analiz ne demek satışla
pazarlamanın farkını bilmiyorum Ondan
sonra dedim ki yani orada benden
beklenen Hani birini seç onunla ilgili
bir cevap vermek değil mi çoğumuz ne yap
atarız Han ded ki öyle olmayacak dedim
İkisinin de ne olduğunu anlatırsanız
Hani ben ona göre seçeceğim dedim hani
hangisini istediğimi ve hangisine daha
uygun olduğumu aslında bu şeyin çok
güzel bir örneği karşı tarafın neye
ihtiyacı var tam olarak neyi duymak ve
anlamak istiyor Ben ona ne cevap
verebilirim O yüzden her zaman karşı
tarafı anlayıp onun ne ihtiyacı var
oradan girmek çok daha etkili Yoksa siz
kendiniz de dünyanın en doğru olan
şeyini anlatırsınız ama Arş tarafın
ihtiyaçları ya da isteğiyle ya da sormak
istediği şeyle örtüşmüyor hiçbir anlamı
yok Bunu ben bir de çocuk gelişiminde de
ve çocuk yetiştirmekte de çok anladım
hani o çocuğa Senin konuşman hiçbir işe
yaramıyor O çocuğun derdine bir önce onu
anlaman gerekiyor
gerçekten bir diğer alışkanlık da
Sinerji yarat yani çok basit olarak 1 +
1 eş
3 farklılıklardan güç alan yaratıcı
çözümlerle tüm paydaşları memnun et
yine mülakattan bir örnek vermek
istiyorum yine png mülakatım bu sefer
başka bir direktör bana dedi ki ya ded
bizim mülakatlar akadem başarı vesaire
böle başarı kriterleri
dediğimiz tane özellik işli
liderlikte iletişim halinde ol gi
kriterler bana bir sor
bü konularla il sorduğu sorular liseden
cevap vermiş ünitesindeki
deneyimlerim yaptıklar İşte topluluk
kurulu vard fse kard atımı vard or buu
burada şurada burada böyle bir şey oldu
Gibi ekler vermişim iş M son dönem daha
ünited
bana
birun şeye girmedin mi dedi Vallah dedim
girmedim Çünkü dedim bir kentteki dedim
kulüpteki çocuklar dedim süper dedim
Birkent dedim çok Asosyal yani o kulüpte
çok Asosyal dedim Hiçbir iş de
yapmıyorlar dedim ben girmedim dedim
Bana o mülakat yap dedi Normalde öle
şeyler yapılmaz çok da kibar çok da hala
sevdiğim bir insan ama Aman dedi siz ne
anlarsınız ki zaten dedi sizin dedi bir
kentte Tek bildiğiniz dedi cik C giyinip
etrafta piyasa yapmak
dedi Ben de dedim ki bir burs
Zaten ben de dedim ki A dedim Niye öyle
diyorsunuz dedim Benim
dedim hani bıyıkları olan burslu
mühendis kız arkadaşım da var çok iyi
anlaştım Kanka BMW'si olan süper piyasa
kız arkadaşım da var dedim Hani bizim
öyle okul gibi okul değil dedim Ondan
sonra ve bana dedi ki senyor ikiyle bir
arkadaş olun tüm arkadaş oluyordum Çünkü
farklılıklar çok değerli yani ve bu
farklılıklar değerli bunlar değersizlik
tüm farklılıklar çok değerli
Eee ve Aslında Sonradan anladım ki
Eee P'nin çok istediği bir şeymiş bu
yani çok farklı background daki
İnsanlarla iletişim kurabilmek takım
olabilmek ve bunlara Değer vermek çok
önemli bir şeymiş Ben orada bir atar
yaptım diye düşünürken Mülakatta kadına
Bozdum Ne yapıyorum ben falan diye
Aslında çok iyi bir puan almışım
Eee son alışkanlık
da baltayı bile ne demek bu Abraham
Lincoln bir sözü Eğer bir ağacı kesmek
için 6 saatiniz varsa ben bunun 4
saatini baltayı bilemeye harcarım bunu
da nereye
bağlayacağım bilmiyorum aranızda
sabahlayanlar var mı sınavda çalışıp da
başarılı olmak için
var değil mi Ben hayatımda sabahladım
bayağı Hani inek bir öğrenciydim Hani
hep
ilkokuldan üniversiteye Hatta şimd iş
yaşa kadar ama hiç sabahladım
sabahlayanlar Tabi ki takdir
veriz
farklılıklarını takdir ederek
karşılıyoruz Ama şu çok önemli uyumak
yemek yemek Bunlar insanoğlunun
İnsanoğlu 21 yüzyıl versiyonunun
gerçekten olmazsa olmaz ihtiyaçlar biz
bazen bunları unutabiliyor Aman
toplantım var Yemek yemeyim Aman ödevim
var uyumayayım öyle değil Gerçekten siz
ne kadar iyiyseniz ortaya çıkardığınız
işlerde o kadar iyi Siz ve bu Sadece
uyumak ve yemek yemek değil Neyse sizi
geny Neyse sizin ruhunuzu besleyen ondan
hiçbir zaman ödün vermemelisiniz Çünkü
bunu yaptığınız anda yoldan çıkıyorsunuz
sizin kendinize Önem vermeniz yani o
baltayı hep Keskin iyi
tutman sizi o yolda tutan
şey kadar hızla giderseniz gidin Eğer
yolda değilseniz bir anlamı yok bunun
bir örneğini de yine bu üniversiteye
hazırlık sürecinden vermeye çalışacağım
Bu arada bayağı zorlandım bu örnekleri
bulurken aradan 16 sene
geçmiş ama buldum
hatırladım yine üniversite hazırlık
sürecinden anlatacağım Tabii çok yoğun
bir dönemdi işte geceleri çalışıyorduk
Okul sosyal aktiviteler işte hala
atletizm her şey Devam Ediyor hafta
sonları dershaneye gidiyoruz işte ev
çıkıyorum ve şöyle bir karar vermiştim
ben hafta sonu ders çalışmak yok Hafta
sonu test çözmek yok
E ne oluyor Annem de beni sadece hafta
sonları görüyor Annem dedi ki bir gün Ya
kızım sen ded ÖSS'ye Hazırlanıyor musun
dedi ben senin bir tane soru çözdüğünü
görmedim
dedi Çünkü neden benim kuralım var Hafta
sonu ders çalışmak yok O benim hani
kendime ayırdığım kendimi biraz daha
yenilediğim nefes aldığım ik
gün bayağı kızdım bayağı kızdım Bir daha
bana hayatı boyu ders ya da işle ilgili
hiçbir şey
söylemedi Gerçekten bu dengeyi kurmak
yani hani tamam ÖSS'ye hazırlıyorsunuz
da siz de insansınız Yani yine canınız
yine Erkek arkadaşınız olacak yine kız
arkadaşınız olacak yine sınamaya
gideceksiniz yine Neyse size zevk veren
şey Sadece oturup böyle boş boş
bakmaksan yine onu yapacaksınız
E bunu yaparken de Kendinizi çok iyi
hissedin kendinizi O büyük amaçtan zaman
çalıyor gibi değil aslında o büyük amaca
ulaşırken çok güçlü bir baltayla
Eee işe sarılıyor musu musunuz gibi ve
baltayı güçlendiriyor musu gibi
hissedin son sözüm de hayat sizin öyle
yaşayın Hani Hayat başkasının ve sizi
bir yere götürmeye çalışmasın hayat
sizin ve Siz istediğiniz gibi yaşayın
Çok teşekkür
ederim